hey everyone I'm Katie snoots and I'm a
youtuber and I've documented my
struggles with acne on my channel over
the past ten years today I'm gonna be
showing you my top tips on how to cover
blemishes so if you wanna see how to
perfect your base keep on watching so my
first top tip for covering your
blemishes is to make sure your skin is
well moisturized I'm going to be using
this moisturizer from it cosmetics it's
bye-bye redness and it's really nice
because it has a nice green undertone
which is going to come to balance any
breakfast so I'm gonna apply that and
rub it into my skin blemishes can tend
to be reflate key and that would just
draw attention to them so that's why
moisturizer is super good idea
so following on from that we want to
cover any redness and on the color
spectrum green comes balances red so I'm
going to be using this Revlon Photoready
color correcting pen just to apply it on
any of the redness and blemishes do not
worry if this looks a bit crazy at first
I'm gonna be putting my foundation and
concealer on top but this is just like
mute all the colors down I'm just going
to pop some of that on the back of my
hand
and I'm going to use my fingers to Pat
it into any of my benches
it does look crazy this is this is like
the fun part
the thing about acnes that everyone can
relate to it everyone has either
suffered with it or know someone who has
and so if you do suffer with blemishes
please don't feel too embarrassed or
ashamed because we can all relate to it
and there are things we can do to help
our self-confidence and uncover it as
well next step is foundation I'm going
to be using this new foundation from
benefit it's the hello happy software
foundation I give it shake and again it
pops some that on the back of my hand
and off in with a brush so this now
should completely cover any of that
green toned concealer we pull thorn and
give us just a really nice airbrushed
finish I'm quite particular about what
tools I use for each kind of step with
my foundation routine so I always use a
brush to apply my foundation just
because I think it blends everything in
a lot nicer than your fingers good
however for concealer I always use my
fingers because I think the warmth of
your hands can really like melts the
product into your skin for a nice like
even coverage beautiful next step
concealer now I've kind of covered and
smoothed everything out into one shade
but I still have a few pesky blemishes
around this area which I just want a
little bit more coverage on it so I'm
gonna take my it cosmetics bye bye
under-eye this is a really thick really
creamy pigmented concealer which will
cover absolutely everything fingertip
that's slightly in now this is so thick
this concealer so you just want a tiny
bit on each one and then I'm just going
to tap that in so now that you've got
this beautiful base you want it to stay
in place all day so there are two ways
two options to do this with first up is
a setting spray this one from Urban
Decay is amazing it's the all nighter
literally makes your makeup last all day
even in the summer and then the second
option is a powder this is the beauty
baking powder today because it is quite
toasty I'm going to be using the Urban
Decay's spray you just want to hold this
about ten centimeters away from your
face and spray in like an X so you all
like aspects of your face get sprayed
with a good amount or product
[Music]
so I really hope you've enjoyed this
video and learned lots of tips on how to
cover your blemishes if you have enjoyed
it be sure to comment down below share
with your friends and head over to
Glamour at UK's YouTube channel to see
more videos like this
[Music]